miles de rusos rechazan combatir en la
guerra luego de que el presidente
Vladimir Putin anunciara su movilización
parcial a Ucrania en la oposición
convocó a protestas que dejaron más de
1.300 arrestos en al menos 38 ciudades
del país desde la cárcel el líder
opositor ruso alexei navalli se
pronunció
el tamaño de este crimen y la cantidad
de personas involucradas está aumentando
y esto se hace solo para que una persona
tenga este Poder Personal para
prolongarlo Putin está atormentando al
país vecino matando gente ahí y ahora
arroja un gran número de ciudadanos
rusos a la picadora de carne de la
guerra
tras el anuncio del primer reclutamiento
militar de Rusia desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial cientos de Nacionales buscan
abandonar el país lo que hago Todos Los
tiquetes aéreos que se vendieron por
precios exorbitantes Turquía Armenia
kazajistán Uzbekistán y kirguistán son
los destinos más atractivos para huir
debido a que No exigen visado ciudadanos
rusos sin embargo muchos aprovecharon
que por ahora no hay restricciones para
los más de 300.000 reservistas que
pretende reclutar el kremlin como este
hombre que prefirió no dar su nombre
Porque me hicieron mi amor hubiera
comentado todo Si pudiera Pero sabes lo
que me podría pasar por eso creo que
todos lo entienden y nadie apoya la
guerra es muy doloroso ver morir tanta
gente me gustaría que esto terminara
rápido
por su parte la fiscalía de Moscú
amenazó con castigos de hasta 15 años de
prisión a las personas que participan en
manifestaciones que la ley rusa prohíbe